SPEAKER: The 2021 State
of DevOps Report released
last year--
it contained findings
about how teams navigate
key areas of software delivery.
We talked with two of the
researchers, Dustin Smith
and Dave Stanke, about the
report's section on security.
Hi, Dustin and Dave.
Were there any
surprising findings
in this section of the report?
DUSTIN SMITH: You would
think that the more steps I
add into my process,
the slower it will be.
But I think it's really
about how teams are
integrating these practices.
And are they doing it by
looking at their entire system
and figuring out
how they can best
fit them into the actual
process so that it is seamless?
And that should be the idea
with any of these practices.
And we find that teams that
implement these practices
are actually delivering software
faster and more reliability,
and all while seeing value
driven to the business.
DAVE STANKE: So one thing
that we found consistently,
and yet I'm still
surprised by it every time,
is that we don't have to make
a compromise or a trade-off
between delivering fast
and delivering well.
We found that teams that have
the best secure code practices
actually are the
same ones that are
delivering the most frequently
and having the shortest
lead time from code to delivery.
So we really can have both
fast and market responsiveness
and security and reliability.
SPEAKER: What exactly did the
security section of the report
focus on?
DUSTIN SMITH: I think one
of the important things
to clarify with how
we looked at security
is that we weren't
looking at things
like how many vulnerabilities
did you experience
in the last year.
We weren't measuring
how secure is your team.
Instead, what we
focused on were what
practices have you
implemented on your team
in order to detect and recover
from security vulnerabilities
in an effective way.
That's one of the
key differences
that we try to focus
on for several reasons.
One of the main ones
is that people may not
be willing to share how
many vulnerabilities
they've experienced.
But they are willing to
share what practices they've
built into their process.
SPEAKER: What did you
find separated elite teams
from the rest?
DAVE STANKE: The real
fundamental thing
that we see is they do
something called shifting left
on security.
The teams that are
succeeding are the ones
that are bringing security
principles, knowledge,
and practices leftward
into their testing,
into their initial
development processes,
and making it something
that is known and practiced
throughout the organization.
They make a lot of use
of automated testing
to make it so that known
vulnerabilities can rapidly
be detected and kicked
back for remediation.
And something that really
high-performing teams
like to do is having guardrails
or pre-approved libraries,
things that developers
can pull into their code
with the assurance that those
have been vetted by experts
and that they're going
to pass their security
tests because they've
already been built in.
The security practices
have already been built in.
DUSTIN SMITH:
Elite-performing teams
are more likely
to build security
into their entire
development process.
And so that means not throwing
over your most recent change
to the security team and
asking for approval right
before deployment and hoping
that they do it quickly.
It means pulling
them in earlier,
right at the design doc phase.
Are you including
your security team?
And then are you
including security reviews
throughout your entire
process as well?
And then do you have tests that
check for known vulnerabilities
built into your build process?
And finally, do you have
pre-approved libraries
that you can pull
into your project
and know that those versions
of those dependencies
are pre-approved and secure
and ready to be used?
SPEAKER: How can teams start
implementing these practices?
DUSTIN SMITH: I'd
say go to the report
and look at all the
practices that we've outlined
and try to identify
some of those quick wins
that you could get.
Where are the low-hanging fruit?
And one of the nice
things about the report
is that we also include industry
benchmarks for each practice.
So you can get a
rough idea of to what
degree has this practice already
been adopted in the industry.
That should give
you an idea, even
if you haven't met with
your team yet, of where,
potentially, are we lacking.
SPEAKER: What would you say is
the core idea from this section
of the report?
DAVE STANKE: Really, the meme
is security is everybody's job.
But that doesn't mean
that it's not your job.
There can be an
unfortunate interpretation
that says, well, if
it's everybody's job,
then I'm covered.
I don't need to worry about it.
Well, the bad news is
it's your job, too.
And we find that
teams that succeed
are the ones where everyone
in the organization
really internalizes the
importance of shipping
secure code.
Now, that doesn't
mean that we expect
every person in an
organization to be
a security expert and a
worldwide leader in software
security.
Instead, what we like to
see is a consultative model,
where an organization has a
team of real security experts
who are creating
guidelines, creating
pre-approved pipelines,
and generally educating
the organization about how
to incorporate security
into their work.
And then everyone
throughout the organization,
from design to implementation
to testing to operations,
all can reflect that
knowledge back into the work
so that it's incorporated
in their day-to-day jobs.
DUSTIN SMITH: I think the
overarching principle should
be that we need to move from
being reactive to detective
vulnerabilities and more
proactive and even diagnostic
and just noting
that vulnerabilities
are, essentially, inevitable.
And so we need to
be able to come up
with practices and processes
in order to recover from them
when they are detected in a
way that is quick and scalable.
SPEAKER: Where can
users go to learn more?
DAVE STANKE: We've got a great
resource on our Google Cloud
site that incorporates this
year's State of DevOps Report
as well as previous years'.
It's got a capability
catalog that
shows all those
capabilities I mentioned.
And for each one,
there's an article
that talks about what it is, how
to measure it, and how to get
started practicing it.
There's all that
and more, including
a self-assessment tool
that I really recommend.
You can check it all
out at g.co/devops.